se ha producido un cambio significativo
en la tarjeta sanitaria en francia
actualmente el pase sanitario es un
requisito para entrar en bares
cafeterías gimnasios cines lugares
turísticos y trenes de larga distancia
pero ahora se necesitará una tercera
dosis las personas que hace más de siete
meses recibieron la segunda inyección y
no se han aplicado el refuerzo se
enfrentarán a que su tarjeta quede
desactivada esto aplicará para cualquier
persona mayor de 18 años los jóvenes de
12 a 17 años podrán seguir utilizando
sus pases sin una tercera dosis la
tarjeta sanitaria se ha vuelto vital
para la vida cotidiana este pase
sanitario es necesario para todo
básicamente sin él no podemos vivir sin
un predio hacemos lo que tenemos que
hacer para tener algún tipo de vida
social todos juntos estos cambios se
producen mientras el gobierno busca
convertir el pase sanitario en un pase
de vacunas más estrictos el sábado por
la noche el senado aprobó la segunda
lectura de un proyecto de ley para
aplicarlo más de 50 mil personas
protestaron contra las medidas
propuestas en toda francia el proyecto
de ley se había varias veces
ya que los senadores y los diputados no
una conclusión este domingo se realizará
la lectura final del proyecto de ley en
la asamblea nacional